for people who don't know like
um you and blast you got a new record
out but like you guys are
very much rooted in this game together
yeah um
you know a lot of people who who are
just getting up on blast don't realize
he's
kind of like god knows he's not new he's
been a factor
in the scene as far as being a producer
engineer i mean he's can do it all
you know um he's kind of like la's russ
but you know russ always brags that he
mixes and masters and records himself
and makes the beat i'm like yo blast
does all that [ __ ] i would say more like
he like a
like the new quick for sure nah for sure
but like you guys
got got it out the mud together and you
had told me some stories about like some
early stuff with you in blast but kind
of give me
a background on how you guys met and and
your guys just kind of
come up has been kind of synonymous you
know what i'm saying um i met blast
um i went to school with his nephews so
like
i was at school rapping and [ __ ] like
that so i guess it was going on like
it means to do that to school cash or
whatever so we
were working with some of the uh we were
around some of the same people
early because his nephews were rapping
and it was this producer and carson's
name uh named joseph he went by stunning
b
but i know blast was like recording and
[ __ ] at stun the b crib
right but like one it was like christmas
break of like 2008
damn like we had linked up uh everybody
had went up to
cal state dominguez again from carson so
everybody went to cal state dominguez
was like having this football game
and blast came up there with his nephews
that was my first time oh wait
yeah i met blasto oh hey that's a long
time ago man
yeah it's 13 years ago yeah so
at what point in time did you guys start
to have like a creative
relationship where you guys started to
make music together so
we did a song back then i think i did my
first song with blast when i was like
16.
he had this he sent me this record it
was called go hard this was the first uh
the first song i ever did with blast was
called go hard so he sent it to me
and i recorded it at home and i sent it
to him and
he was like yo can you uh send me like
the wav file
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] you
know i found out later like the first
person that put him on
like mixing this [ __ ] was chris o'bannon
shout out to chris o'banos
was around back then too um but yeah so
um
yeah we did that record back then i
don't even know if that [ __ ]
ever um came out but um
what ends up happening i want to say
i always just was seeing them around
like going to different [ __ ] like
leaving parties and coming
to the denny's and carson and seeing him
and the homie pj there and just
going out to uh spots and running into
him and then um
i had did the la cipher which was uh
breezy in the street [ __ ]
and blast was doing all the beats for it
et cetera so i went up there and i did
it
and i um i won and so like one of the
prizes was like uh
you do a session with blas and bias does
the beat or whatever
something like that so i um i had pulled
up
and i recorded with him but at the time
um
i was recording with this dude named
kaitel which is reasons
engineer so i had a session but
the day i had the session with kytel he
told me his studio burned down
jesus so i asked blast could i couldn't
record
the record with him right i was doing a
verse for
my homeboy from my neighborhood k-stone
so i pulled up over there
i did the record with blast and i just
started recording with blast on the
regular after that
so this was yeah i want to say
2016 maybe so you guys have kind of
reconnected around like we were seeing
each other like
i was right but following each other
creatively you guys
started your stride around we started uh
we started back like
being around each other like on the
regular like 2016.
yep so i was over there like we was in
the studio with each other every day
um just moving around and then
yeah [ __ ] blast was
i think when i um trying to think
i did yeah we did a song we did a song
called uh
called signing off i remember i sent the
record to blast
and i was out to eat man i was at olive
garden and i got the verse back
i heard i went in the car i mean i went
to the bathroom i'm listening to the
oh [ __ ] this like it was a rap verse
like blast i rapped on the song
but not only did he uh rap on it i was
making my own beats at the time and
blast i
did a additional production on reckon i
was like oh [ __ ] like
that added something to it so then other
records i was doing i was sending blasts
to
you know yeah yeah what you got for this
one right right
right so it just became like a that's
fire man but yeah
that's my boy a lot of people um like i
got i was telling you off the camera
like i got a dm
when priority drop [ __ ] asked me
like how would you pay for the feature
man how did you get a blast future and
how much
did you pay for it and i was just like
damn like that's crazy you know
i'd be having to remember though
blasters bro that's just
life right now you know what i'm saying
so a lot of people that don't that don't
know
the history they'll never know like okay
well [ __ ] like this actually
my boy like we didn't actually did
things for each other etc you know what
i'm saying but
now yeah [ __ ] with blast that's like one
of my my friends it's not really like a
rap
right no it's a it's a friendship for
sure um i know bro parents like he
met mine right right that's wild man
yeah now he's scorching right now yeah
hottest [ __ ] in l.a for sure i would
say on the west coast
yeah i'll give him that too you know
what i'm saying like i mean i i mean
it's he is
he's definitely in that conversation